las personas que sufren de diabetes
tienen una mayor probabilidad de
desarrollar muchos problemas de salud
incluidas enfermedades cardíacas
este video Le explicará cómo se
desarrolla la enfermedad cardíaca Cómo
afecta su salud y qué puede hacer para
ayudar a reducir su riesgo de enfermedad
cardíaca
si sufre de diabetes esto significa que
su glucosa en sangre o azúcar en la
sangre está elevada
con el tiempo un nivel alto de azúcar en
la sangre puede dañar los vasos
sanguíneos de su corazón y otros órganos
lo que puede ocasionar otros problemas
de salud
esto significa que mientras más tiempo
tenga diabetes mayor Será su riesgo de
enfermedad cardíaca
existen diferentes tipos de enfermedades
del corazón que incluyen enfermedad
coronaria miocardiopatía
arritmias e insuficiencia cardíaca
la enfermedad coronaria es una
acumulación de una sustancia llena de
colesterol llamada placa dentro de los
vasos sanguíneos de su corazón
[Música]
la acumulación de placa en la enfermedad
coronaria puede aumentar su riesgo de
tener un ataque cardíaco
la miocardiopatía se refiere a las
enfermedades de su músculo cardíaco
la miocardiopatía puede provocar latidos
cardíacos anormales llamados arritmias
la miocardiopatía también puede causar
insuficiencia cardíaca
esto significa que su corazón debilitado
no puede bombear suficiente sangre para
satisfacer las necesidades de su cuerpo
sufrir de diabetes y enfermedades
cardíacas a la vez le puede afectar de
muchas maneras
tendrá un mayor riesgo de sufrir otros
problemas de salud graves como un ataque
al corazón un accidente cerebrovascular
e incluso la muerte
le puede resultar más difícil realizar
sus actividades diarias
es posible que necesite ayuda en cuanto
a cuidados personales
es posible que también deba tomar más
medicamentos
vivir con estas condiciones puede causar
depresión
la buena noticia es que hay cosas que
puede hacer para ayudar a reducir su
riesgo de enfermedad cardíaca
por ejemplo Puede que sea necesario
realizar unos cambios en su estilo de
vida si fuma obtenga la ayuda que
necesita para dejar de fumar tanto el
tabaquismo como la diabetes pueden
estrechar los vasos sanguíneos lo que
puede aumentar sus probabilidades de
desarrollar una enfermedad cardíaca o un
accidente cerebrovascular mantenga o
alcance un peso saludable
siga un plan de alimentación saludable y
realiza actividad física de forma
regular consulte con su proveedor de
atención médica sobre la cantidad
correcta de actividad física para usted
asegúrese de trabajar con su proveedor
de atención médica para controlar el
nivel de azúcar en la sangre el
colesterol y la presión arterial
esto incluye tomar todos los
medicamentos recetados por su proveedor
de atención médica incluida la insulina
y las píldoras para ayudar a reducir el
azúcar en la sangre la presión arterial
y el colesterol
el seguimiento del plan de tratamiento
acordado entre usted y su proveedor de
atención médica le ayudará a sentirse
mejor y a reducir su riesgo de sufrir
una enfermedad cardíaca